[Musique]
anna a acheté au condo il ya quelques
années lors d'un barbecue son voisin
arrive avec onair victorieux et des
signes de dollars dans les yeux il a
contesté son compte de taxes municipales
et la ville a révisé à la baisse
l'évaluation de son condo la ville lui
rembourse 2000 dollars en trop perçu en
plus son taux de taxes baisse
substantiellement anna tombe de sa
chaise son condo est identique à celui
de son voisin son évaluation exactement
la même
elle voit déjà les économiquement le
lendemain elle appelle la ville pour
faire ajuster son évaluation mais trop
tard parce qu'on ne peut contester son
évaluation que dans les quatre premiers
mois de la première année du rôle et le
rôle dure trois ans c'est ce que 3,1 à
fait mais pas anna la période de quatre
mois où il passé elle devra donc
attendre le prochain rôle d'évaluation
pour retrouver le droit de contester le
fin mot de l'histoire
votre maison est surévalué ne comptez
pas sur la municipalité pour vous le
signaler